SHE HAT BEEN FOUND.
LEARN MOREN EMOF
HEEMY S ONTROL, IS, DO JOE, U'OG
>> THAWAMEN U.S.
PREND THT
IDEME.RUTTK
HIRESIDENT JOE
BIAMD ES AIN KEYSTONE STATCAMPAS
YEARS WHERE P
APPEARS TO BE LOOKING EA
R RERALLCNN'S KRISTEN HOLMES
>> Reporter: FOR PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMPN PENNSYLVANIA
TWO OF HAND-PI
EDIDATES SOU
CE AIRING HIS GRIEVANCES ON HISN
CLTOO REON
POLITICA, O LUTELYATN INVADED TH
HA.POD THISABUSE OF THEG TO
BEFOREE A CKLASHTHE H BO
PRESEN RE SA
STATE.
IT GOES TO SHOW YOHOW CRITICAL
THISTE
BELONG RETIRING REPUBLEY.DEMOCRY
OPUNK UPT NE
ICAN CONGRESSMAN PENNSYLVANIA YS
N'Y S THCHOW CCACOMMENTAE EARLRI
WILKES-BARRE TONIGHT AS YOU P TN
THATMATION.T SO SURE THAT THEFO
THA
TOJUST BG UP
UT HSESTLIN
BITHEXP INSERTO
G THS
ISYET OTR
. OINE P SN'T D TN SW
O DOHAWHEN TRUMPNDAN
>>YOUT MP MAY
R FOR THES
THE ATACK
THON
DEMOCRATICANRA
LUTELY.
IN FAC THAT'S WHAT A MID BEABIDO
YOU WANT THE ELECTION TO BE  ONE
AND THE K  KEYTH UPCOMINM EL
UP A
RECENTLY.STILL NOT
DOLD BRDINARILBY
OULD FACE SOMEEALEMS MIDTERM.
CANDIDATES AND SOME SWINP IS OUY
LIKE DOUSTATES, U KNOW WHO HAVE
YS.
ESE -- I WOULD BE H REHAEY
I T S WILLTHE HOYPE